search crews are racing to find victim
stills trapped in Southern California's
very deadly mudslides the storm that
triggered walls of mud and debris killed
at least 17 people 17 others remain
missing at this hour we learned the
identities of two people who died they
are mother and realtor Rebecca Riskin
and school founder Roy rotor hundreds of
emergency workers are breaking through
rooftops and poking through the mud in
the search for victims more than 75
miles away in Burbank new video shows a
car racing down a windy road trying to
outrun rushing water and mud Carter
Evans is in Montecito northwest of Los
Angeles where hopes of finding survivors
are dimming Carter good morning good
morning rescue crews say they've covered
about 75% of the search area right now
but the scale of this disaster is so big
I gotta be honest with you the pictures
are hardly doing it justice right here
so imagine it's 4:00 a.m. you're
sleeping in your home you hear some
rumbling because that's what everybody
said you wake up you wonder what's going
on and then BAM you get slammed by these
boulders in a wall of mud and and they
don't just hit the home they go right
through it and this is a small boulder
most of them are the size of cars the
debris field from the deadly Montecito
mudslides covers 30 square miles search
dogs are assisting in the ongoing rescue
effort but for responders time is
running out friends and family members
are joining in the search as well Josie
Geller is missing aiding Gower is
desperately trying to find his mom Josie
we're just gonna go down the creek and
see what we can find
he says she was swept away clinging to
her homes back door her boyfriend
survived hanging down there for six
hours until they rescued him in the
morning calling out her name all night
long bedrooms upstairs
if she just would've stayed upstairs the
mudslides destroyed at least 100 homes
damaged 300 more mangled cars and downed
power lines even seasoned rescue teams
are shocked by the magnitude of the
destruction we don't see this I mean it
is complete devastation
I'm multiple multiple homes that are
completely destroyed and still we have a
lot of people that are unaccounted for
oh my god mark O'Farrell's cell phone
video captures the moment the powerful
wave of mud and debris roared down hill
I basically ran for my life I ran as
fast as I could made it back to my house
within about 30 seconds of the the front
of the flash flood hitting and it hit
within a matter of minutes leaving many
with no time to escape as you can
imagine most of the injuries that we saw
from this event were related to
fast-moving debris as you can't even
fathom what these poor patients went
through to finally make their way into
the emergency department and even people
whose homes were not affected by this
mudslide are still going to have
problems for quite some time for
instance the water infrastructure in
this area has been seriously damaged
there is no timeline to fix it the busy
101 freeway there's still debris all
over it in places and right now they
don't plan to open it until next week
Nora can't even fathom it as the doctor
said Carter thank you so much